[Music]
all right what am I going to talk today
about so I'm gonna talk about optimizing
applications for scalability so it's
like one of them more for me more
important points while keeping costs at
base are gonna talk a little bit about
some techniques and then things that
sometimes are overlooked to keep costs
in control
one morning in the beginning this will
be somewhat opinio a talk so I made
choices on the products that I show
today there are many many more products
out there this is really a hardware so I
okay if I won't build application that I
want to be able to scale and still be in
my budget these are the products that I
would choose so I will concentrate on
that that is like basically a side note
for you that you know like if there are
products missing what am I going through
today is I give a little bit of
introduction basically terminology that
I use and then I go through the full
stack of my applications of presentation
layer applications persistent locks
analytics and then talk a little bit
about related session and resources
where you can find information a bit
about myself just two words or maybe
three I'm a cloud developer advocate for
the Google cloud platform so basically
we are the interface between developers
and operators building on top of our
platform and the developers and
operators that built a platform inside
the company so you we are your voice
into the company and we are the voice of
the engineers outside so please feel
free to reach out to me if you have
things very things like we can improve
where you have challenges also if you
have good stories and you just want to
tell us about it how amazing certain
things are please please reach out to us
we want to relay that back to the
engineering team so you can find me for
instance on twitter under the name at
haas diversity all right just a little
bit of a pulse check who is here today
like who is an engineer in the room
alright majority that's my audience cx0
i TDM
okay so most most engineers so what are
the criteria is that I go through today
when I'm looking at some of the products
of the Google cloud platform so first of
all I gonna look at performance
performance what I understand under that
is basically the response time like how
quickly an application responds
especially if you are in the upper
layers of your application you want to
have things being snappy so you want to
have like very low latency in terms of
our at times and know like processing
time so to say this is especially
important in human interactions they
don't want to wait for a second or even
half a second till something loads up
right second point which is important
for me is reliability so what happens if
there's something that fails is there
like a failover it says some redundancy
there that can help me to like have my
application still up and running
even if part of my of my application
fail the third part and that is part of
the title is the scalability so what if
like what happens if my application goes
viral and like my user base grows do I
have to react attack completely do I
have changed system change products that
I'm using or can I just use them from
user 0 to user 1 billion and last but
not least also part of the title are the
costs now costs are not only the costs
that you get charge on your credit card
or if you are having offline billing
with us installed you have to paper like
Bank wire probably not only these costs
are considered you should also consider
costs like migration cost costs like of
operation like what is the human labor
that your company has to put in to
manage certain systems right so yes
there are systems out there that are
cheaper than others and it looks like
why would I pay more but the labor cost
adds up and so you have should consider
that as well that's why you see in the
cost section not only the money back you
see also the people involved there and
it will make a couple of statements
along those lines along this talk all
right so what I do I understand on a
full stack application you saw it in the
agenda already
so I for myself consider a full-stack
application being a presentation layer
so basically assets that I serve that an
application layer which basically has my
business logic and processing and a
persistence layer which is basically my
storage a database things like that on
the side I have onto one side like
service API so things that you can call
out into the Google out platform or you
know like at other providers or even on
premise and on the right side you have
like logging in analytics which is
integrated in a lot of our products but
you can also integrate that into your
applications that you're writing all
right so let's start with the
presentation layer so my choices of
presentation layer I'm a big big fan of
firebase firebase makes it really really
easy to start coding getting something
up and running and part of the five
raised platform and ecosystem is the
firebase hosting so you see on the right
side there you have like a portfolio of
things that you get out-of-the-box with
firebase being like authentication
database no SQL database fire store blob
storage cloud storage log functions for
processing and hosting for like hosting
static assets now it's very easy to get
started with firebase but firebase has
also very simple course structures and
so that might mean at some point if you
are at a certain scale that they're more
affordable solutions out there for you
to save some costs so my second choice
here is especially if you're looking at
scale is cloud storage and cloud CDN so
why am I like what am I looking at in
terms of like the four criterias that I
I mentioned before so if you look at
performance we're good right
they are snappy like CD ends like
firebase hosting is also backed by a CDN
so they are basically at the edge points
which we have around the world for
Google cloud platform so low latency is
great reliability static assets are easy
to replicate right so you catch them
everywhere in the edge cases even if one
of your edges falls down or multiple
even they can be fetched from other
edges so we have four applications we
are also reliable and
scalability again you don't have like
like strong consistency constrains for
static assets if you if you have higher
ones you can set your cash like timeout
basically loads like that the cash is
refreshed more frequently but in
basically since it's static assets that
we can replicate scalability is not an
issue either and when it comes to cost I
mentioned already firebase is kind of
like a static cost and it's lousy and
cloud storage are a little lower so what
does it mean in in detail what what are
the cost drivers for my presentation
layer so one of the big cost drivers is
Equus so because it's basically all the
bytes that we ship out of the Google
Network to your clients to your
customers these are the things like
where you have to look into and they
become again in firebase you have
basically flat rate for small
installation that is fine there will be
like no difference between the solution
that you use but if you go and larger
scale then equals actually goes down
depending on the traffic that you have
so increased traffic you get basically
down in what you pay per gigabyte for
your equals and that only gets like you
can only benefit from that if you use
Google Cloud storage now if you want to
go even lower in the prices that you pay
for equals and you can use a CDN in
front of cloud storage which incurs a
fillip cost so you have to basically
ship some data into the cache you pay
that but then the the equals cost from
the CD ends is is quite a bit lower then
like if you compare it for instance with
serving data directly from cloud stores
so if you are a large scale please look
into a cloud CDN and in front of Google
Cloud Storage this will be much more
affordable than if you look at standard
firebase or just using cloud storage now
the second one is my application layer
and for the application layer I chose
like three kind of categories so cloud
functions is available on GCP as on
Google cloud platform as well as under
the firebase for Allah and brending so
you can use it directly from your
fire based applications you can trigger
them from like HTTP you can trigger them
in firebase for instance if you have any
data changes in your new SQL data base
in the real time database or in fire
store that is available on the fire a
firebase so if you have any data changes
you can automatically trigger your cloud
function cloud function under GCP you
can also trigger where for instance on a
pops up message so pops up is our
messaging system which is scalable
beyond belief at least my belief you
don't have to like do any kind of sizing
or anything decisions you just pump data
in there and it will arrive at the
destination where you want to have it
and that is globally as well so that
that is also trigger than you can use
for cloud functions and another trigger
that you can use is any kind of storage
operations so for instance if you use
cloud storage which is our blob storage
if you store a file or modify a file you
can also trigger a cloud function to do
any kind of post-processing if you want
to the second choice for my application
layer is App Engine so App Engine has a
couple of really nifty and nice features
its scaling down to zero for instance
it's flexibly scaling so there are like
some comparison for comparisons that you
can draw between cloud functions and App
Engine but there are also some some
differences and then the third choice is
basically kubernetes engine which is
running container so it is our managed
kubernetes Cuban leaders is in container
Orchestrator
where you can run your containers and
Google needs takes care of restoring
them if they fail its taking care of
node management or source management
things like that you can install a
service mesh in coupon leaders to have
like discoverability you have security
in there things like that so there are a
lot of more things that you do manage
yourself in kubernetes which are managed
for you in points and app engine in
cloud traction so let's have a look at
our for quite years I know they all look
green I have a couple that are not green
just to mention that but basically if
you look at cloud functions like
performance reliability so cloud
functions
unless it's like the very first call
which takes a little bit of a warm-up
but if you have follow-up calls then
they are really snappy they're like in
like no tens of milliseconds depending
of course of yourn you're processing
like how much processing you do in your
cloud function but if you for instance
just return a hello world you can get
into the tens of milliseconds and
response time in terms of reliability
cloud functions is running on our
infrastructure it's also like basically
you just can scale very easily
containers and if they are one falls
down we can just reroute the traffic to
another one that is a life and they are
in a inner region so they can be brought
up in different zones so even if a soul
becomes unavailable your cloud function
is still available in terms of
scalability I mentioned as say they are
like order of seconds so if you have to
warm up new instances of your container
which runs the cloud function it is
usually at the order of a very low
second range now for App Engine it's
very similar story so App Engine has
certain constraints in terms of like
processing if you have a fondant
processing job it's like constrain to
like 60 seconds after 60 seconds we
basically time it out in cloud functions
you have 9 minutes to process after 9
minutes we basically stop the function
processing so these are boundaries that
you have to consider if you do certain
kinds of business logic for app engine
we have background processes which are
allow it to run much longer I don't have
the exact number right now but they are
allowed to run much longer if you need
to do some asynchronous background
processing now for coupon leaders if you
inside the cluster you still have
resources available then you can scale
at the order of milliseconds so bringing
up a part is pretty fast
unless you do a lot of warm up in
initialization in your part but I'm a
big fan for instance of rally writing
goaling apps nowadays and I statically
link these binaries and put them in my
container that makes the containers very
small so even if they have to
fetched from a registry and then they
are started up like in milliseconds like
really really really quick now if you
run out of the sources in your
kubernetes engine cluster you need to
scale the cluster and that is basically
adding compute engine instances and that
is at the order of minutes so it takes
about 30 seconds to bring up a compute
engine instance and then it takes about
another 30 seconds to basically set up
the whole internet coburn eaters stack
which we need to manage that note now
the advantage of kubernetes is also you
don't have any kind of like runtime
restrictions there so you basically you
run your container like it can run
whatever you want in there but basically
runs on the Linux kernel you can run
your container on there and you don't
have like restrictions like how long it
can run and get stopped or things like
that now what are cost drivers for
Google Cloud functions or GCF Google
function GAE is Google App Engine G key
years kubernetes engine what are the
cost drivers here so for functions you
have basically an instance type that you
can choose its memory and and processing
power based so CPU Hertz based you see
there it's from 128 megabytes to
gigabyte based on the size that you
choose you have a certain cost per
second for for that in what are the
instance and then it's basically also
called currently depending on like how
many calls you have we basically time
like how long do you function is running
and then we calculate the cost there
everything like all of those what's
coming in is the e Chris as well now the
advantage of the equals for these ones
is that for cloud functions is a
baseline so you basically pay the same
no matter if you call it once a day or a
hundred thousand times a day or million
times a day for for App Engine is the
same now for kubernetes engine we price
the equals based on our standard
networking prices and the networking
prices is based in a sense of that the
more traffic you have to lower the price
goes for equus so
you know that if you have a big in an
application which gets viral your
application will become cheaper over
time the more traffic you get if you run
it on Queenie's versus App Engine or
Google cloud function now one node to
that like if you run kuba need is even
if you're uncommon eaters engine the
managing of your applications on who
vanitas will incur labor costs you have
to consider that now yes you have that
also with App Engine you also have that
with functions but there are a little
bit of difference in the magnitude how
much management labor cost management is
there now for the decisis basically if
you have jobs which require a lot of
memory or a lot of like CPU power you
are out of luck pretty much and GCF and
GAE they are like capped at for it
Google App Engine at one gigabyte memory
for GCF at two and have 2.4 gigahertz of
processing power now for kubernetes
engine you basically can take big
machines like take your sort of 64 core
machine with 2 terabytes of main memory
and if your part needs a terabyte of
main memory so be it you can do it so
consider that as well if you have some
really like heavyweight processing you
might want to go more to a gke based
system than than something else all
right number three and that is more that
is basically my big passion as a Google
developer advocate for the cloud
platform is the persistence layer so now
we have a couple of different types of
persistence products there the first one
that you see here is cloud storage so
cloud storage is basically a blob store
so if you have any kinds of objects that
you wanna store any kinds of assets then
cloud storage is what you want to use
cloud fire store is our newest Corel
document so to say document database
where you can store data without having
to prettify in a schema and you are that
it's very flexible in terms of it can
grow for in terms of processing as as
well as data are very flexibly
cloudsql you have like basically a
managed MySQL PostgreSQL sour relational
database system which is horizontally
scalable now if we look at cloud source
and fire so in terms of reliability
scalability performance they are pretty
snappy they're very quick the really
nice feature of cloud storage is that
listing is a strong consistent so if you
add a file to cloud storage and you are
at the other end of the world and you
ask if that file exists it will give you
a strong consistent view if you look
from two places in the world let's say
it this way if you look from two places
in the world at this roughly the same
time you will get the same view of what
the data you have in flower storage that
it's not true for for a lot of other
systems that are out there in the world
in terms of scalability they're very
scalable these systems you don't have to
look at sizing or anything you basically
start from zero and you crow it close
with your application you don't have to
worry about you don't have to give us
any sizing information or any of this
now if your app gets really really wide
Ryle like I don't want to name the
company but there are certain companies
that build their whole business on App
Engine a data store which is the
predecessor of fire store now if you get
at that like billion dollar valuation
kind of scale please still talk to us we
want to make sure that your business are
runs reliable and gets the performance
that you need so we give you some
dedicated resources for that now if you
look in the relational database area we
have cloudy skies clouds banner now
that's where my first non green check
marks are coming or crosses if you look
at cloud SQL in terms of like
reliability now cloud SQL is out of the
box basically a single host system so if
this system falls down you become
unavailable so you don't have
necessarily out-of-the-box
out-of-the-box replication now what you
can do and with cloud SQL and the Google
cloud platform is you can actually set
up like a failover instance and you can
set up reader application
lately out of your system but even if we
have to fail over - your failure was
this failover database it will incur a
little downtime it will take some time
to basically catch up with the logs and
stuff like that now if you look at
scalability for cloud SQL for instance
you can upsize your your cloud SQL
instance so you can scale it vertically
you can jump between different different
sizes of instance sizes between cloud
SQL but they are at some point caps
right you have a maximum instance size
that we can support and if you outgrow
that you are out of luck pretty much
unless you are building your application
on top that can manage to distribute
your application workload across
multiple cloud SQL instance but if even
if you upgrade your your instance then
you are at the order of at least minutes
if not hours to basically do that
upgrade and your customers can't access
or do things with your application
during that time now if we look at cloud
spanner this was designed with the idea
in mind to actually eliminate these
boundaries eliminate the boundaries of
scaling and eliminating the boundaries
of having maintenance even if it's
planned maintenance outages now cloud
spanner is still even though it gives
you the quality still a relational
database with strong consistency so we
have strong consistency across tables
regions and even globally that you get
there and you can do no downtime updates
so you can basically add nodes or remove
nodes from cloud spanner depending on
your workloads and you can also update
your schema which is running in the
insider transaction as well even while
you're are serving live traffic so now
what are the cost crimer through cost
drivers for cloud storage file store SQL
and spanner so for cloud storage is
basically the storage and equus for fire
storage you are charged based on the
operations storage and again equus you
have heard that by now a couple of times
cloud SQL based on the instance type
that you choose and
if you have a fail over instance and
read replicas that basically adds to the
cost as well so if you want to have
higher availability and the disaster
recovery that's basically what you pay
for and now it's been a recharge your
based on the configuration that you use
so configuration is basically do you
want to have a regional instance do you
want to have a multi region continental
instance or do you want to have a multi
region global instance based on that we
charge different amounts of money per
node that you provision with us and then
yeah basically the node count that you
choose is what drives the cost and again
also we have equals cost there that you
that you incur now how can you optimize
on these levels so one optimization that
is many times overlooked in a cloud
storage is the storage classes that you
have so the storage classes is we have a
multi region storage we have a regional
storage class we have near line and we
have cold line and especially if you go
too near line and cold line the storage
costs at rest goes down a lot now there
are certain things we can of course like
storage costs go down but we cannot just
like lower the prices without giving
some constraints on these so if you go
too near line we recommend like if you
have data that is not accessed more than
once a month then it's worse to move
your data to in your life if you access
it more once than more than once a month
then you will actually incur more costs
because we give a little bit of penalty
for retrieval of data if you if you use
near line now code line is basically for
something where you want to have
archival or like backups that you don't
hope and expect to use so cold line is
for or something for legal reasons that
you have to store for a long time
cold line is if you access data less
than once a year
so if you access data once a year or
twice a year like : is already more
expensive than a regional instance now
the really cool thing in in Google cloud
platform for Google Cloud storage is
that these these storage classes are not
or you can
define buckets so you can define buckets
where your objects go in and then all
your data that you go in goes into that
bucket gets that storage class but
that's not the only way to have storage
classes for your objects you can
actually use one bucket and have
different storage classes for the
objects in their bucket and so there's
something called object lifecycle and
for the object lifecycle you have the
option for instance a like okay if that
object is not accessed for like say 30
days please move it to Nearline if it
hasn't been accessed for like 365 days
please move it through to a cold line
and you could have find these policies
and this is done automatically for you
so you don't have to like you to find
these policies once and then you say
like I'm off the hook over time the data
that I'm storing it's gonna be getting
cheaper for me all right so you don't
have to keep that at top of the minds ok
like I have to run like a cron job that
basically moves these these objects now
another thing that you can do that I did
in a demo at i/o is for instance if you
have certain plops that come in like
videos or images or something like that
that you do a processing off so you do
like for instance generate some
thumbnails or you do a redo coding of
your videos or things like that and you
want to keep the raw image or raw video
footage around but you know you're not
actually serving that very often you can
write after you process your data you
can change the storage loss of that raw
object and you basically say like ok I'm
processing the data right now once the
last process is finished I move it to
cold line and you're done all right so
you can do that on with our like client
libraries and our AP ice as well so you
can do that programmatically now for
fire store what I recommend to basically
keep costs under control look at using
limits like how many data you get
returned from from your queries look at
curses and offset so basically you can
use a curse or if you do paging that you
only really get the data into your
application and and presentation layer
that you actually serve in to your
customer or to your user don't they like
get all the data and do
I'm processing if you do that every time
you incur basically a lot of costs on
these operations so we have costs
attached to reads writes and delete
operations on on fire store and another
recommendation is to do analytics
outside so consider if you store data
and you use it operationally in fire
store for your application if you do
want to do analytics over your data
consider moving that data out for
instance into bigquery for cloud SQL
things to basically look out for the
keeping costs under control use the
right size the right instant size of
course like to approach actions where
you cannot grow so that you don't have
to change the instance aisle every month
but and like how your traffic pattern is
but the instance ice is basically your
corner hilarity that you can choose to
to have costs on the control and then
you have things like fail over in read
replicas so don't just like right away
create a read replica if you don't need
it so there are certain capabilities of
your cloud SQL instance out-of-the-box
where you don't necessarily need to read
replicas so read replica comes in if you
if you hit basically the boundaries of
your cloud SQL instance in terms of like
right and reach throughput if you want
to get a little bit higher in the write
throughput you can consider a read
replica which will take away a little
bit of the work from your from your
master or leader node and then you can
with that get a little bit more Headroom
in in the right throughput on your on
your instance now for cloud spanner we
recommend to scale depending on your
traffic on your workload basically so do
some tests like watch how your traffic
is for your application and the you are
charged on a granularity of an hour on
cloud spanner so don't do scaling like
every 10 minutes so basically do a
little bit like like space scaling a
little bit hours so your power you pay
for node anyway for an hour so consider
that if you program any kind of scaling
for your cloud spanner instance all
right number four is locks and analytics
and before I gonna go in locked in early
I want to show really quick I mentioned
cloud firestore and I want to show a
little demo at least for cloud fire
stores I going to switch to my laptop
here and some of you might have seen it
already we have it as a showcase demo so
basically what I wanted to show with
cloud firestore is it's very easy to
keep multiple applications on different
platform different platforms and devices
in sync so we allow something that you
can watch for data changes in firestorm
this is a feature that we had for for
the real-time database under under
firebase and so what you see here is
basically the console for full file
store and the firebase and you see here
we have a database one we have some data
we have some rules basically who can
access the data you can define indexes
or remove indexes if you want though
and you can see the usage basically of
like how much data will be processing
now in this demo what I wanted to show
is the scalability that it's possible of
a firestorm so the demo is I have
devices which are watching a document
I'm going to show you really quick this
document we have basically here a
document that can change a color every
time I change a color tense hours and
imitated devices are catching that data
change they get basically notified about
the changing color you just saw changing
they get notified about the change in
color and once they get that they write
that back actually to firestorm so this
this color that you see here is in my
import document I for input documents I
split up basically firestore logo into
four pieces and then you see here a
color and the time stamp every time you
see a change these devices report that
back to the database now how do I want
to visualize that the way that I'm
visualizing this is I actually have here
on the left side the the firestore logo
and each pixel each to each color pixel
is represented by one device now if I
change the color you see here the color
get the color change gets basically
propagated to these 10,000 devices per
section in total we have 40,000 devices
every time a color changes
they get basically propagated and then I
display that in my display app and I
didn't have to do anything for that and
in terms of like looking like how do I
notify my devices or things like that I
just use the client libraries and all
this is done automatically for you right
the next thing that I want to talk a lot
about a little bit is locks and
analytics so we have a couple of
products there that help you to analyze
your usage patterns your data that you
are collecting that you want to analyze
to for instance to machine learning to
get insights into your business to find
out like what what works reliably and
what what doesn't so the products of my
choice here in that area are bigquery
which is basically an OLAP national
database for massive scale data
analytics and I show a little demo in a
second the second one is cloud dataflow
cloud dataflow is a data processing
infrastructure and and basically
platform where we have a library or
vaisya programming model that we open
source under the Apache Beam umbrella
which allows you to write data
processing pipelines that work both in
streaming mode and in batching mode
which is very powerful and then if you
have any kind of existing data analytic
pipelines for be it like in Apache
Hadoop or an Apache spark you can run
these basically and microwave them busy
in kind of a lift and shift manner and
run them on Cloud Data proc so now if we
look at all these metrics again in terms
of scalability reliability and
performance performance well they are
not end-user
like infrastructural products that you
use you don't use these products to
serve something that directly to your
users so don't use pay query if you've
like directly connected into your
application if you use big way please
cache do some caching on top of it
otherwise your users have to wait a
little bit of time so query runtimes and
bigquery are usually at least a second
all right they're like this is not a
real time
like fast answering machine and it's
just by the nature how bigquery is
designed now for cloud dataflow it's
pretty similar like 48 are going through
data flow that incurs like some
latencies so you don't want to rely on
that either basically these are acing
system to use in acing matter and then
Cloud Data Park as mentioned it's a
system for you that you can use Apache
Hadoop or Apache spark on it and they're
like in terms of scalability and
performance they are all built on Google
cloud platform on our infrastructure and
we make sure that these are up and
running especially if you look at
bigquery I haven't like they're running
on so many machines even if a machine
falls down and another one picks up the
work and it's similar for cloud dataflow
now what are the cost drivers for these
systems if you look at bigquery it's
basically a scanned data or like what
your query
touches in terms of data storage which
is very reasonably priced it's pretty
much priced on near line and cold line
prices for for cloud storage so you can
actually keep your data in bigquery and
you don't have to move it out into cloud
storage or move it back in bigquery has
also heard of my Federation board so you
can actually use data that is directly
stored in cloud storage and query that
data now we don't have the data storage
optimizations there so queries will be a
little bit slower but you can if you
want to directly query data that is
laying in storage now for data flow you
pay for virtual CPU so you pay at GCE
instance and then the virtual CPU you
pay like how much memory you want a
provision for that you pay for the
storage that you use and the data that
you that you process basically we have
some cool services on the data flows
that we have a shuffle service which is
outside of your instances which uses a
novel way of shuffling your data which
can free up a lot of like the size
requirements on your instances so if you
use our shuffle service you need smaller
instances to process your data so you
can save on that in
you pay us a little bit for their
sharpening service which is also more
performant and faster on data Park
basically gze instances that we use so
you can use the instances that we have
available you can also customize your
instances for your for your pipelines
that you want to use and you pay a
premium a data prop premium on top of
this per be CPU a per CPU I believe and
the the what we charge is like at the
minimum of one minute but we charge it
for a second and then the choice is
basically what you have for saving costs
if you look right away on the cloud data
Prague is one you can use preemptable
VMs so if your jobs allow you basically
that machines become unavailable if we
reclaim them and your job can pick up
these the work from a machine that we
reclaim then you can use preemptable VMs
and preemptive ramps are considerably
cheaper than GCE instances that you you
basically can keep so take that like
consider that to optimizing you cost on
the analytics side for cloud dataflow
you have the possibility to provision
standard persistent disk or SSD so a SSD
is also considerably more like higher
priced and then standard PDS so that's
also something to consider based on your
requirements of like how fast your
analytic pipelines have to run so that's
something that you should test basically
for your workloads what is cheaper if
you run with SSD then maybe your
pipelines are shorter in the time that
they need and you can run like you pay
less for the instance cost but a little
bit more for the persistent disk so
that's something that you should take to
check on your on your workloads and for
bigquery what we optimize is to what we
recommend for optimization is run your
queries on a small data set first make
sure that your queries are optimized on
a small data set don't run them on your
entire data set you will incur a lot of
costs every time so run it on a small
day does it optimize them that they read
as you
of data as possible and then you can run
them across your entire data set that
you want to do and then another option
is you have the choice between on-demand
and flat rate billing for bigquery so
consider if you are running a lot of
bigquery queries or jobs then considered
to like our flat rate pricing which can
help you as well to save some cost all
right let me show you let me show you a
quick demo for for bigquery I just want
to show you the cheer like amazing
amount of data that can it can crunch
and a little bit of time so here what
I'm gonna do is I want to look at all
the Wikipedia articles that have
happiness in their title from 1st of
July till today so I'm gonna run this
this job and that goes against the data
set that we basically have in terms of
page views on Wikipedia which is updated
constantly and you see here we have like
a nine second query for hundreds or
gigabytes of data well that's cool nine
seconds hundreds or gigabyte it's maybe
not that impressive let's see how that
is if we look over the entire year so
far so it's from first of January till
today again you see there in this query
that I'm actually doing records now
I'm cashing I don't want to cache let me
uncashed and let me run this again by
the options so basically I'm looking
again for the same happiness in the
article and I'm running that's for the
entire database entire like data that I
have for this year and I'm doing on each
of the titles of racks no records like
it's not like so straightforward you
actually have to look into the data and
like you can't use like an index or
things like that necessarily so what you
see here I processed one terabyte of
data in 20 seconds now we have actually
demos where we process petabytes of data
in in under a minute or around a minute
so like bigquery is really really
powerful and processing vast amounts of
data and you pay basically for the data
that is processed all right in terms of
resources and related recessions where
can you find out about pricing so we
have a pricing calculator on our webpage
it's cloud that Google becomes less
product search calculator where you can
choose between the different products
and size them and then you get a price
basically an estimated price what you're
gonna pay another thing that I want to
mention is that we have a free tier we
have always like free tier basically for
products until otherwise stated but for
now it's always it's basically every
month that you get a pre free tier and a
lot of the products that I mentioned
today actually have a free tier so you
can try them out and even if you write a
small app you could end up paying
nothing and running that application so
consider that if you want to check out
GCC and then in terms of sessions that
to look into I have a couple that I
recommend to look if you care about
costs and keeping costs under control so
first is the managing costs and gtp it's
talking about the structures that you
can that you have to manage costs and
gzp another one is about controlling so
the that one was yesterday it's recorded
it's on youtube so you can check it out
on YouTube
another one is controlling cloud costs
which TCP in panels converting that one
again was also yesterday is also
recorded I would look into then we have
one on monitoring and forecasting as
well as like how to look into your
billing data with bigquery and data
studio so the one bigquery data switch
is happening right now so again you need
to use YouTube to check that out and
then we have one two more on monitoring
forecasting on GP
[Music]